that's another really really good point
is uh serial daters with a really high
notch count
um it's pretty difficult to establish
um guys typically lie about theirs you
know
they'll make it twice as big as what it
is and women usually tend to have it or
maybe even cut it by two-thirds but
um you can usually tell by
i mean paul what do you think's a good
way you know if you can kind of distill
it to
figure out what a woman's notch count is
times whatever they say by 35 no
[Laughter]
it's um well what i look for is
behaviors so you you know
because it doesn't intrinsically matter
we we look all right we know notch count
is an is an indicator of an inability to
pair bond over time
that's what the research shows right we
know that high notch count
are treating you're treating people like
they're disposable commodities which is
a common place for narcissist or bpd
people so it correlates
we know that about nash count the
problem is they're never going to be
honest about
their notch count particularly during
the love bombing phase
that jonathan talked about and he
illustrated the three
phases of a narcissistic abuse
relationship
so what i look for is behaviors
and even when they talk about things in
their past or history
things that would indicate inability to
pair bonds so for example
is she a serial dater who went from
boyfriend to boyfriend was never single
or a lot of times you never hear about
that but i mean if there's a complete
absence of any kind of a long-term
relationship
and it's like well you know i lived in
argentina and then i was in georgia for
a bit and i spent some time in asia and
it's like
you know you get a lot of moving around
where there's no stability and
consistency
they're usually moving around on
somebody else's dime right
of course no long term now this is not
something that's particularly in the
relationship but
they don't have good long-term or
long-standing friendships
is a pretty good indicator because they
burn their bridges
with their friends and their family as
they kind of go along through life and
so
they don't have anybody that they've
known for 20 years or 10 years you know
i mean
since they were a teenager that sticks
around for very long
that's just on the friendship side um
but you know i look for
one thing that's a really good indicator
is that they talk about
or had a painful breakup and then took a
break from dating for a while
because what that demonstrates is that
they had an ability to pair bond
so they were bonded to this person they
had a painful breakup that hurt them
and so instead of running out and
jumping on the carousel
and trying to fulfill their need with
their supply need potentially a
narcissist with all these other
dudes body parts they're instead taking
a break
right because they're hurt by that and
they're not sure where to go next and
so they bury themselves and they take
four five six months of not dating not
being with anybody
and if they volunteer that information
you're not if you create an environment
where you should do this during the
plate spinning or dating phases
where you create an environment where
women are
open to talk to you without feeling free
of judgment
you know so if you just are able to just
kind of create an environment where they
don't feel like they're being judged
you know and and that they're being
accepted they'll tell you things
um and a normal girl will tell you too
about things that that where they've
made mistakes which i know
women don't often personal
accountability is kind of a handicap for
a lot of women even who are not
diagnosable but you know a good strong
indicator if someone's a little bit more
self-aware
might say some talk about mistakes
they've made a narcissist won't do that
especially you know a culvert narcissist
is going to be the victim always bpd
women
they're usually always the victim you
know they're not going to say
that they did this or that or you know
what i mean if they
described they mentioned that they
cheated before for example
the guy would have deserved it or i i
cheated but you know i mean he was
abusive to me and what else did you
expect me to do you know what i mean
it's gonna be all the excuses for their
bad behavior
and how they're still a good person even
despite their bad behavior
now women kind of do that anyway they
need to be the good chimpanzee i call it
you know they need to be seen by the
social circles as being
a good person that's an instinctual
drive but they will do it to a level
where
you know there's just no personal
accountability yeah there's a lot of
mental gymnastics that they'll jump
through in their head like they'll right
they'll jump through a lot of hoops i
mean basically whatever number you get
you can multiply it by
by essentially two or three
you